it's a new week and that means new games
are coming out and that's good because
you've already finished the witcher 3
right well if you ever wished upon a
star for a shooter on Wii U your prayers
have been sorta answered Nintendo's
colorful competitive multiplayer shooter
puts you in the form of a squid painting
the battlegrounds to gain turf it's
definitely marketed towards the kitties
but there's an element of weapon tactics
environmental awareness and quick
movement that will separate you from the
competition so you can destroy those
children with your elite shooting skills
start playing super mario sunshine
little cousin on friday the 29th also
this week you put on your flame
retardant robe pull up your sleeves and
start casting magic with Magic ado now
you can cast and dodge at the same time
for more fast-paced fight along with a
new artifact system but rest assured
friendly fire has remained the same so
you can get caught in the crossfire
until you realize what everyone else is
known all along that your friends are
all jerks start collecting artifacts on
the 26 also this week a popular mobile
game get support to everything not
mobile Badlands game of the year edition
is coming to ps3 ps4 xbox one vuv to PC
and Morse you can get reacquainted with
those adorable little slip sprites take
those dark fuzzy creatures and evade
death and fight off machines invading
the woods they won't all make it but
that's why there's strength in numbers
save the clones starting may 26
originally released in japanese arcades
in april of 2014 ultra street fighter 4
makes its way to ps4 this week with all
current downloadable content 1080p
resolution 60 frames per second fight
stick support and more in addition to
the usual balance changes the update
introduces some new fighting mechanics
the first is a new move called red focus
similar to the regular focus move but
having more invincibility hits there's
also a delayed wake up technique which
allows a knockdown player to slightly
lengthen the time before the character
gets back up also based on fan feedback
the update removes most unblockable
setups your fight begins on the 26
gonna quickly mention that cat lateral
damage is coming out on pc this week
showcased in this trailer that's so bad
it makes the room look wonderfully acted
hey Johnny oh hi Danny what's wrong with
mark he's cranky today you're a cat
climbing on stuff and knocking things
over before your human pets get home
simple yet satisfying just watch a game
play clip instead of the trailer finally
rogue legacy makes its way to Xbox one
this week so you can strengthen your
family gene pool to platform your way
past permadeath it's beautiful
combination of grueling difficulty
side-scrolling sword fights and genetic
farting abnormalities it's almost too
close to home charge the castle on the
27th for further details visit gamespot
com release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week